I'm overwhelmed,
I feel like I'm going to have a
good time.
Good Otani
Soi Umagami Ichiro and the latent Literary Born
Cover
I was able to get revenge on my white disciple Hey, cool person Nikkei
bar What is it?
Hey, it's bad to put it in.
Nakamae, I
'm going to talk to your father from now on.
Irregular food warfare of the moon's tradition
Regimando Kyuji - In
other words, it's a whole food war.One point color kk The
last squadron It
seems that you don't understand anything on the same night
.  I've achieved 90% of my plan
.
Even if I become your stagnation
, what does that mean I'll throw away my own thoughts and beliefs and become the dog of God's gastronomy that you want
?
Big senior I'm happy
Today is a good day I'm a really good boy I want you to stop talking like you've already bought it
We will win
I
'm looking forward to the day of the game from the end.
Details will be announced at a later date.
[Music]